okay what happened well the Academy has
has always leaned left in the 20th
century but leaning isn't a problem so
people think Oh viewpoint diversity we
need we need everybody we need Nazis we
need every of you know we don't need
everybody
what we need is no orthodoxy that's
what's fatal orthodoxy so if you have if
you have to feel like sociology or
social psychology in which it's two or
three to one left to right that's
totally fine with me that's totally fine
because if someone makes some claim
that's just like ideologically blind
someone will say you know common sense
other evidence that you've missed and
then the system works but what what I
learned when I started down this road in
2011 I gave a talk at the big conference
of social psychologists I gave a talk
about this problem that we're losing our
diversity that I could only find one
conservative in the entire field and I
gave a talk on this and and so what I've
learned since then is that the ratio in
psychology was between two to one and
four to one left-right all the way up to
the early 90s we've gathered together
all the studies we could find so all the
way up to the early 90s it's only three
or four to one left to right which would
be okay but then between 1995 or four
and 2010 it goes to fourteen to one do
you have any idea why and why that time
yes so so it you get the same story
whether you look at Republican Democrat
ratios or liberal conservative there
they tell the same story so the two the
big things going on there are one is
that the greatest generation which had a
lot of Republicans so a lot of men go
off to World War two they they're on the
GI Bill they enter the Academy in the
1950s a lot of them are conservative or
republican so you have a lot of them but
in the 60s and 70s one of the main
reasons to go to grad school and the
social sciences is either a to stay in
school to escape the Vietnam War draft
or B to fight for social justice and
against racism
so in sociology and psychology in
particular in political science maybe
I'm not sure you get a huge influx of
left-leaning people who are there to
pursue social justice so you know the
motives are fine and if it was balanced
to be totally fine but as you get these
young junior people on the Left come in
in the 70s and 80s and then you get the
older people that are more politically
balanced retiring in the 80s and 90s by
the time you get to the late 90s it's
all baby boomers and so do you get up do
you get a positive feedback loop
developing in there like you said it's
like 3 2 1 it's ok but maybe when it
hits 4 to 1 it goes to like 20 to 1 then
you said exactly so you so then you
start getting hostile climate so I wrote
a review paper on this with with Joe
Duarte and Phil tetlock and Lee Justin
Jared Crawford and and we so we reviewed
everything that we could find and we
concluded that most of what's going on
is self selection that is people on the
left and we're open to experience oh
it's banana selection but then there's
really good evidence that there's also
hostile climate I mean it's it's
undeniable now that if you are not on
the left in a grad program there's just
constant little subtle or not so subtle
reminders that you don't belong and look
in the Academy we're all about saying
hey if there are subtle hints here and
there you can't succeed right I mean
that's what we do for a living is we say
that little things will stop people
well little things are put in the way of
anyone who doesn't fit politically and
so you do get hostile climate you do get
overt discrimination there's evidence of
that and then there is also it is part
of the story here that what it means to
be a conservative in the 90s and
especially to thousands have changed so
it is true that you know that the
concerns were not in any way
anti-science until much more recent
times now actually all sides are
anti-science about different Sciences
but in America the the right wing the
Republican Party
it's controversial but I do believe that
the polarization starts with the right
moving further out so what it means to
be concerned to be anti anti
evolutionary which is actually what's
happening on the left now - exactly yeah
so every well as modern man talked to
Brent Weinstein the other day and you
know he one of his claims is that
evolutionary biology has something in it
to offend everyone
so it's a it's a science that's very
likely to be targeted by extremists you
also brought up something that actually
touches on the idea on the difficult
problem of how it is that you might
define someone who's ideologically
possessed let's say or ideologically
rigid because the idea was that you can
make a valid case for the utility of
free information flow and and the free
flow of people that would go along with
that and you can make a good case for
the danger of that and so the idea might
be that if you're only making a case for
the danger of that then you're tilted
too far to the right and if you're only
making a case for the utility of that
then you're tilted too far to the left
exactly that's right and so we can look
at immigration as a nice example there
was a recent essay in the Atlantic I
think it was by Peter Beinart where he
he reviews it starts with a lot of
quotes that are pre nuanced positions
about immigration from Barack Obama Paul
Krugman and a bunch of other people on
the Left who used to be able to say on
the one hand you know compassion
economics on the other hand you know we
have to have a legal process and there's
a threat to low-wage workers so people
on the Left used to be ale to talk about
immigration and talk about the pros and
cons the pluses and minuses but by now
it shows how in the last four or five
years you can't if you so much as
suggest that well maybe immigration is
on net good but it might have some
deleterious effects on certain classes
of low-wage American workers you could
get in big trouble right because that's
instantly prejudicial you know because
immigration has become a sacred topic so
this is the key thing that I want
everyone to keep in mind we are
fundamentally religious creatures were
built for religion and it's a great
achievement to create a scientific
establishment and an academic
establishment that keeps that way of
thinking out scientific thinking is not
natural thinking religious thinking is
natural thinking and what's happening to
us in the last few years especially is a
flooding in of religious thinking and so
let's get a bunch of social scientists
to talk about immigration what are they
going to do look at the data way up the
pluses and minuses no they're going to
many of them feel they're on a team and
that team is fighting the right the
right is anti-immigrant it includes
racist elements
therefore that justifies us in being pro
immigration and social sciences are
always there's always ambiguity there's
always conflicting studies yes there's
multiple causal factors is that always
in the social science study that's right
so by nartz point was that the left used
to be able to think straight about
immigration clearly it had a you know
it's generally pro immigration but it
used to be able to think straight but in
the last few years a religious Orthodox
mindset has overtaken it okay so we
might as well also point out that it's a
primordial religious mindset right
because I mean there are every Christian
or Jewish
I mean ancient tribal small-scale lots
of gods right right well so then one of
the things that you might suggest is
that when you throw out a sophisticated
religious structure an unsophisticated
religious structure comes in to fill the
gap I do so that's true okay definitely
worth thinking about so that's right so
that's right the thing to fit with
religions we have to clarify
fundamentalism as the problem not
religion and so if you close I'm
tribalism that's right if you get a
fundamentalist you know I'm happy to say
and if you have people applying to a
grad program in psychology and I find
out that they're Christian that's fine
there's no problem but if they're
fundamentalist Christian I would think
well let's say let's say it's not
psychology suppose it's you know geology
so someone applies to a geology program
there are fundamentalist young earth
creationist are you gonna admit them no
I don't think you should they're not
able to do the right kind of thinking
based on what we know to be the case
they're not in a scientific paradigm not
incentive that's right
so so if we wouldn't admit a
fundamentalist Christian to a geology
program why would we admit someone who
is just as fundamentalist about certain
moral and political issues into a
sociology program or into a psychology
program if they come in knowing what the
right answer is committed to that right
answer likely to get angry at anyone who
contravenes that right answer and and
showing signs of closed mindedness I
don't think they belong in a yeah I
guess the question is how in the world
do you set up mechanisms to ensure that
you're not swamped by fundamentalists of
any sort so
are people who are reducing everything
to a single cause at something like that
how can you implement a structure that
protects the organization against that
without the structure itself becoming
totalitarian you know because these
things these things spin out of control
so fast yeah but so you know I think
what we have to realize in the Academy
is that we face I think we face an
existential crisis we rely an enormous
amount on public good will we get
enormous tax subsidies direct research
support and recent polling shows that
while Democrats have always had a higher
opinion of the universities and
Republicans until two years ago
everybody thought universities are a
good thing they make life better so
Americans been very supportive of higher
education they're been rising gripes on
the right but it's only between 2015 and
2017 that now Republicans go from saying
mostly universities are good things in
two years they go way down and say the
universes are bad things they're making
things worse now how is this news
greeted pundits on the Left are saying
oh those Republicans are so anti science
look how ignorant they are they now hate
universities come on anybody who's been
watching the news anybody who's seen the
mobs the shout down to the illiberal
behavior you know the metaphor I use is
like you know Americans on the right and
left are really supportive of the
military we have one of the few
institutions that we still hold in high
esteem on both sides and so the
Republicans more than Democrats so
suppose you had Gallup poll and I
showing Republicans like the military
more than Democrats but both really
liked it then suddenly in 2015 we
started seeing video from all over
military bases and military academies in
which the military leaders are overtly
right-wing they're there they're saying
terrible things about leftists and
progressives and the Midshipmen and the
cadets and everybody is mobbing the
occasional liberal and - behaving in a
really despicable scary and intimidating
way what do you think the left would now
think about the military obviously
support for the military would plummet
that's what's happening in America with
universities we are losing the support
of half the country this is
unsustainable
especially in red states where
they control the purse strings so I
think we have a major crisis I think
we've got to go into crisis mode and
we've got to clean up our act so just as
we're doing in psychology with
replication project we recognize that
our methods weren't good enough and
we're doing a crash course thanks to
Brian Nosek and others the open science
project we're really trying to improve
our game
thank God we need to I think we have to
do the exact same thing about
partisanship and our dude